good evening members and officers of the
council and welcome to the meeting of
the standards committee there is a new
system that is recording so can i please
ensure that you use your microphones
when you are talking because apparently
it's not very clear if you don't use
your microphone
if the firearm alarm is activated please
vacate the offices via the stairs either
through the security door to the left of
the chair or opposite the lifts in the
foyer please do not use the lifts please
assembly in hawley square on the green
and officers will assist you and advise
when it's deemed safe to return to the
chamber
does anyone intend to film the meeting
please note the meeting is being live
stream for members of the public except
for any item of business or exempt or
confidential information is considered
following the exclusion of the press and
the public from the meeting
the meeting is also being recorded and
will be broadcast on the council's
youtube channel
with everyone present please ensure
their mobile phones are turned to silent
and they are not used to make or receive
phone calls in the chamber while this
meeting is in progress
would any member wish to speak on the
council procedure one please announce it
now
no good
we have received apologies from abs of
absence from councillor crowe brown and
mr lee welbrook
are there any other apologies
good
minutes of the meeting held on the 24th
of june i moved that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 24th of june 2021 be
approved and signed as a correct record
could i have a second to please
thank you councillor scoby unless anyone
objects to the minutes i'll take them as
agreed
thank you
item agenda three are there any
declarations of interest
no good
item agenda four
his recommendations from the standards
assessment subcommittee
estelle
would like to introduce this report
thank you
thank you chair good evening members
so item four are recommendations from
the standard subcommittee these
recommendations arise out of the
subcommittee's consideration of a number
of complaints over the last few months
about councillors membership or use of
social media groups and sites
the subcommittee sees that there is some
lack of understanding within town and
parish councils and perhaps with
district members as well
about how involvement in social media
sites or groups might impact on a
members decision making in during
committees
for example by constitution by
constituting a conflict or a particular
interest
the subcommittee recommended therefore
that the council sources some specific
training about social media for all
councillors and also for those town or
parish councillors who might be
interested
the subcommittee also recommends that
the existing guide to social media in
the constitution is updated to include
the latest advice from the local
government association
on the use of social media by
councillors
so
those are the two
recommendations from standard
subcommittee before you tonight and i'm
happy to take any questions thank you
councillor douglas
um
yes so it says that the training should
be offered and then
the existing guide should be updated i'm
just wondering if those two things
should be
sort of like the other way around or if
it makes any difference that
um
so that
the so that we we know what the
what the guide is before we do the
training sort of thing
um
and i suppose i just suppose we need to
be careful
i thought that people can obviously be
part of a pressure group but they just
need to be careful
what they say we need to make sure that
that distinction is made
yes absolutely and i've that's been one
of the problems in some of the
complaints that we've dealt with that
there's been
um
the the standard assessment subcommittee
has given some informal recommendations
on a couple of these complaints and then
there's been a bit of a frenzy of of you
know soul-searching about
people have been understandably anxious
about the members of facebook groups and
and we've said all along it's absolutely
fine for people to
members of these facebook groups but
then you just have to be a bit
thoughtful about when you're talking
about things or making a particular
decision
about you know what you may have said on
social media or anything like that and
it's quite a difficult area uh i know
other um
people in local councils i've spoken to
have also said that it's quite a
difficult area because of course the
code of conduct precedes
the era of social media because that's
come upon us very rapidly in the last
few years
so um
absolutely the um so the latest local
government guidance on social local
government association guidance on
social media is fairly brief but quite
helpful and and that's very easily
updated into our existing guide
and then following on from that we can
look at finding somebody to come in and
talk about social media and just
make members feel maybe a bit more at
ease about it
um
because we have had a bit of a flurry of
complaints back and forward between
between sort of different groups on
different sides of a debate about
what somebody's membership of a
particular group means and how it means
they can or can't participate and so i
just think a bit of clarity on that for
members would be very helpful
um so so that's what um the subcommittee
were talking about and that that was
what uh what they've recommended but we
can certainly update the guidance very
very easily it wouldn't take very long
at all
i'd just like to add to that that
the problems we have come across i think
is the right expression that myself and
estelle are actually going to visit
parish and town council meetings so we
can have a face-to-face meeting with
them to explain the gray areas to
hopefully that will clarify anything and
just stop this plethora of complaints
that are coming through
thank you
yeah that's uh that's fine chairman um
yeah we've had
way back now this has been a problem for
a long time that we've had meetings uh
within our own parish uh to establish
some sort of code with regard to social
media well i see i mean you're saying 20
should be offered
is that literal that you'll offer it or
is it going to be a compulsion
yeah i don't think we could make it
compulsory but it would be offered and
you know obviously people would be
encouraged to come and we we would look
um
to do it whatever way is best for people
so we could maybe offer it online or
offer a session here in the council
chamber
so we just need to look into it and see
what's easiest for people to access
and there might also be some e-learning
the dreaded e-learning
which everybody's horrified about but we
might be able to find something that can
you know as well as offering some uh
in-person training that we could maybe
offer some uh
e-learning sessions in support that
people can choose to dip in and out of
so i don't think we could make it
compulsory but you know hopefully we
would encourage people to attend
are any other questions
thank you um i'm just wondering uh on
the subject of things being compulsory
uh if we have more complaints come in
and it is against someone who hasn't
been um
undertaken the training voluntarily is
there then a case for saying well you do
need to undertake it now and
i still i don't know how you you make it
compulsory but is there a step in
between that that
could be considered
um thanks very much um
the difficulty is if if if say the worst
thing happened and there was a complaint
against a counsellor
in respect of something that had gone on
in in their involvement on social media
um you know we would bring it to
the assessment subcommittee they would
look at it
so far with some of these complaints
there's just been informal action
recommended in order and that can't that
can't compel anybody to do anything it's
just a recommendation that somebody
perhaps attends some training or or
makes an apology or does something
but because it's an informal action we
can't compel that the only way that
somebody could be compelled to do
something would be
if a complaint was serious enough so
that it went forward for investigation
and then you would have an investigation
and if the investigation the
investigator found that there had been a
breach
then there would be
a hearing and then there would be
sanctions imposed and sanctions imposed
from a hearing can include a requirement
to attend training so it's a bit of a
sledgehammer to crack a nut but that's
the only way i think we could impose
compulsory training and later on in the
agenda tonight we're going to
talk about the next report talks about
the areas of training within the council
that are compulsory but there's only a
few
and something like this i don't think we
could unless it fell out of an
investigation and
a hearing and a decision of the um
you know the standards investigation
just say thank you i think that answers
the question
council cop did you
thank you uh two questions are the
majority of these complaints coming from
councillors themselves or is it more a
general public that they're coming from
no they're coming from councillors
themselves
[Laughter]
that's all you need to know really
there has been one from a member of the
public and that's all
does anybody else have any questions
oh
good
in that case
the recommendations are that we need to
agree that training should be offered to
councils on declarations of interest and
issues about membership of social media
groups to include independent persons
and town stroke parish councils
and also to agree to recommend to the
council that the existing guide to
social media
in part five of the constitution codes
and protocols is updated in light of
recently published guidance by the lga
about code of conduct issues and specify
specifically council's use of social
media
to ensure that this goes to the council
obviously we need a proposer and a
seconder
proposed by council fellows and seconded
by councillor bayford
are we all in agreement
item agenda
five this is to do with um
recommendations from the constitutional
review working party and i'll ask
estelle to comment on it thank you
thanks very much chair so um these are
recommendations from the constitutional
review working party there are three
recommendations um
which concern amending the constitution
uh arising out of consideration of these
issues by the group
so the first is a proposed amendment to
the delegations for planning committee
so currently the items which must be
taken to committee and cannot be decided
under delegated powers by the officers
include situations where the application
is by or on behalf of thanat district
council
it is proposed that this statement is
expanded to include specific reference
to situations where the application is
on land owned by senate district council
or owned by a company of which senate
district council is a party
the issue has arisen out of the recent
judicial review decision on a planning
application for land adjacent to leyland
gap school
in which the judge said that the
existing wording
in the delegation covers a situation
where the application relates to land
owned by a company in this case east
kent opportunities limited of which the
council is a party the judge said that
although there was no evidence of bias
in this particular decision there was
the possible perception of bias in the
in the wording of the delegation
and you know therefore it was ambiguous
therefore the proposed change in wording
intends to clarify the situations where
an application will be considered by the
planning committee and remove ambiguity
in the wording
the second recommendation on the paper
is a proposal to amend article 8 in the
constitution which covers mandatory
training for members sitting on planning
licensing and general purposes
committees
the proposal is to amend the required
frequency of training from every six
months to once a year
as the report states this is simply to
ease burden on members and officers
additional training will always be given
when required
and finally the third recommendation is
simply to clear up an anomaly and remove
paragraph five from the council's
protocol for the guidance of planning
committee members and officers
since the paragraph is now redundant
because of article eight
um and that's it unless uh anybody has
any questions you might have some
questions on the first recommendation i
imagine
excuse me can we help
it's a problem
uh it's just a very very minor point on
um the wording at the top of page 12 in
paratu
it talks about the planning committee um
attending at least one session whereas
for licensing board it says one training
session and for general purposes it says
one training session so i'm assuming
that that should be one training session
for planning as well as the other two so
it's just a yeah
that's correct yes
just wonder if it could be corrected as
a typo
yeah i'm sure we can correct that can't
we yeah
anybody else got any comments to make
council bayford
thank you chair um just ask i just
wanted to ask about um a situation where
someone subs on a committee
would they have they would have to have
had previous training
on all three of those yes that's correct
thank you
any other questions
in that case we can move on the
recommendations in the report were
considered by the constitutional review
party on the 11th of november and after
discussion on the matter they agreed to
put the stamp to the standards committee
that members agree the specific
amendment to the planning protocol to
require all planning applications and
applications under planning legislation
to be reported to the council's planning
committee
if thanic council own the land to which
the application relates or if a company
which the council is party to owns the
land to which the
application
relates
we've heard the com we've heard the
comments made by a cell and any
questions raised could i have a proposal
and a second to please
counsel the cup and counselor dealt with
item agenda six is my report
and following on from the two reports
that we've just received
i wanted to say that it's been a busy
do apologize
ladies and gentlemen but the
recommendations
we collectively thought it was in all
three embodied into that recommendation
so what i'll do i'll read all three
recommendations out to you
and the recommendations are
recommendation one to agree to recommend
your council to amend part three section
c
of the constitution
council functions carried out by
committees as follows
2.2 within the publishers laid down by
the council the committee will 2.21
determine individual applications for
planning permission and any other
application made under planning
legislation were a it is an application
which the director of housing and
planning
or planning applications manager
in consultation with the chairman or
vice chairman of the planning committee
considered it to be of significant
public interest
b it is an application which council
members have specifically requested to
be referred to the planning committee in
accordance with the requirements of any
members calling procedure from time to
time approved by the council set out in
the protocol for the guidance of
planning committee
members and officers
c the application has been submitted by
on behalf of a member or an officer of
the council
indeed it is an application buyer on
behalf of thanet council district
council on land owned by the planet
district council or any company which
standard district council is a party can
we break it down into three
recommendations or just do you want it
all as one
uh
you can read them all out okay
recommendation too i know you've got
copies but obviously we need to read
them out
to agree to recommend to council to
amend article 8 of the council's
constitution as follows
8.02 no member or substitute member of
the general purposes committee planning
committee or the licensing board will be
allowed to take their seat on the
committee unless they have received
relevant appropriate up-to-date training
and 8.03
in relation to the planning committee
this is attending at least one training
session
run by the council's planning team every
year
in relation to the licensing board this
is attending at least one training
session run by the council's licensing
team every year
in relation to the general purposes
committee this is attending at least one
training session run by the council's
monitoring officer at least every year
and the final recommendation to agree to
recommend to delete paragraph five
regarding training from the council's
protocol for the guidance of planning
committee members and officers
which states
council appoints members to the planning
committee at the annual meeting
and is legally required to give
preference to the nominations of the
political party groups in order to
achieve party political balance
this will take priority over any other
requirement that the council may wish to
impose on the appointment of members to
the planning committee
such as a requirement that a member will
first receive training
however it is expected that all members
of the planning committee
including substitute members will
participate in initial and regular
update training
and members who are not willing to do so
should decline to be appointed to the
planning committee
could i have a proposal in a second to
please counsel the cup and council dealt
with thank you very much
that removes that anomaly
item agenda six
which is a chairman's report following
on from the two reports we've just
received i wanted to say it's been
extremely busy two months for the
standards committee
you will see from item seven on the
agenda there have been numerous
complaints submitted since the last
standards meeting that were along
similar lines
there was a group of complaints that
required clarification to the
complainants on the code of conduct and
or meeting procedure and as such those
complaints were not taken further
another group of complaints was
connected to the to the need and
procedure for just declaring
interests
in meetings
i think it's safe to say that estella's
commented already on it but it's
obviously a very gray area it's not the
initial peculiar interest it's the
secondary one where you have members of
certain
bodies that are on social media
and whether or not they are entitled to
speak
concerning that subject at a council
meeting and that is where the grey area
is there is a situation where estelle
can grant a general letter of exemption
i think it's terminated as
well we we haven't done this but we've
discussed where there is a situation
where there might be some conflicting
interests which are causing people to
have difficulty
contributing in meetings and whether
whether particular group of councillors
in a town or parish is quite small that
then you know people might perceive that
certain people can't speak or they're
prevented from speaking simply by being
members of these social media forums um
that we could possibly get around it by
issuing a dispensation which we can do
this committee can do actually i don't
have the power but this this committee
can do to enable councillors to fully
participate but i don't think we've
actually got that far yet but we have
discussed that being a possibility um so
we've just sort of talked about it in
general terms but we haven't actually
taken that action yet um so it hasn't
hasn't quite been seen to be necessary
but that is one way that we could go if
it continues to be a problem
does anybody wish to make any comment
so are you saying an example of when a
dispensation might be given
um so for example say you've got a small
parish where you've only got i don't
know a handful of councillors on the on
the parish
uh and say for example i won't use the
social media example but say for example
there's um
oh i don't know there's a
i don't know campaign to raise funds for
a village hall or something like that
that is run by the parish council and
then there's a separate body set up to
manage that campaign of which certain
numbers of the parish council are
members because there's nobody else to
do it
so if
if you came to if they came to a meeting
to discuss progress on the village hall
or to make a decision on the progress of
raising funds for the village all
strictly speaking
um
some of those members may have interests
or conflicts to declare and might be
under the code of conduct might be um
prevented from speaking and fully taking
part so in that sort of situation that's
not maybe not a brilliant example but uh
off the top of my head in that sort of
situation where you've only got a small
parish or
you know a small group of councillors
making decisions if they all had to
declare an interest it would make it
impossible to continue so you can then
individual councillors can apply to
us as the district council and
yourselves as a standards committee to
give a dispensation
which means that they for a certain
number of years up to a maximum of four
years
it enables them to sort of then carry on
acknowledging that they may have an
interest but actually in order to carry
out the business they can they can
continue and participate and take those
decisions
um it's normally where where you've got
it wouldn't
it wouldn't probably impact on the
district council because the number of
councillors but it's more to do with
smaller parish councils
where the nature of what they're dealing
with locally means inevitably lots of
people might be involved
and also the numbers that they have
mean that they they don't have very many
councillors and so the dispensation
regime is there to enable
enable rules to be waived if you like to
enable the the parish council to or any
counsellor to participate in certain
situations it's not just to do with
numbers that there's other criteria
uh which can be which are applicable and
listed in the constitution
um
so
yes i mean i've only ever i've only ever
dealt with it
an application for dispensation at a
previous council not here but but it
does happen and it's quite a useful tool
but it would be a decision for the
standards committee to make
just slightly worried that we know we
stand on political manifestos and you
say i'm against building this housing
estate or i'm against this airport
um
and and actually standing on that
manifesto are you
putting yourself
uh against being able to
act on the planning committee or the
licensing committee for those
things
uh yeah no you're not you're not because
um and what you're talking about is not
so much interest it's more to do with
bias or predetermination or being
conflicted
and the case law about um about bias and
predetermination is actually quite
interesting because councils actually
have a lot of leeway and it's recognized
that in a local context particularly
district or parish or town level
there are issues of real high local
interest and that's what councillors are
appointed to do to argue one way or the
other on particular political lines or
particular
you know views in favor or against
but um
so what so you know that there have been
cases where you might think oh gosh
so-and-so was predetermined and they've
gone all the way to the court and the
court says no actually this is just a
counsellor
promoting what he or she is appointed to
do
and
you know supporting the cause as it were
what you have to be careful of is
again it's just this terrible phrase
sort of approaching a meeting with an
open mind so you may you may have been
elected on on a ticket to oppose
something or support something but as
long as you're not demonstrating uh and
in fact you are approaching these
meetings with an open mind
listening to the arguments
making the decision taking into account
all the evidence then you avoid it
the point is to avoid if you're accused
of something like bias or
predetermination it's at that point that
you have to be able to show
that you've taken these decisions with
an open mind even though it's perfectly
fine to say well i'm a member of this
group and that group and i was elected
on a on a mandate to do x y and z
but i'm here to listen to all the
arguments and i take into account all
the points of view and then i make my
decision
um so that's the point it's not so much
about interest if you're elected on a
particular
to take a particular view or because of
particular stance it's about avoiding
an accusation of bias or
predetermination or in fact being
conflicted
being conflicted or showing yourself to
be biased because of something you've
done perhaps publicly or in the press or
or that sort of thing so
you know i think of you know sort of
attending demonstrations and waving
banners about and that sort of thing but
even then i think there's been cases
that have said well no actually
this this counselor was just supporting
his or her constituents etc so it's
quite a nuanced area and it's quite a
tricky area but the thing is just to
always be careful and thoughtful about
it
and that's you know that's all one can
say really
does anybody else have any comments
the other thing we thought about with
this as well is
try to get some common sense
into the
decision making
counselors when they do go to meetings
and speak having been put on elected on
the mandate and it's very as we've
obviously just identified by this small
situation it's a real gray area the new
guidelines from the lga help
i think tremendously hence why we've
offered to go and
advise parish and town councils
before they overstep the mark and what
is available to them to be able to
discuss
and vote on the subject matter that's on
the agenda
anybody else got any comments
sorry the constitutional review working
party has only met once since the last
meeting of the standards committee and
that's to discuss the topics in the
agenda item five
the last scheduled meeting of the
standards committee on the 14th of
september was cancelled due to the
policy of business
and then we move on to the last item of
the agenda
and as you can see that's the statistics
and when you do look at the back page
of
recent
assessments that we have had to deal
with that highlights
the problem that has arisen hence the
reason for the discussion we've just had
does anybody want to make any comments
i think that sums up then the conclusion
of the business thank you all very much
for attending
you